il
[Applaudissements]
l lundi politique gagne le dantec
8 millions d'euros pour aider le
département résorber les radiers de la
réunion c'est le petit cadeau fait par
la ministre ni gérardin lors de son
passage la semaine dernière
en plus des 1000 contrats aidés
supplémentaires le geste de la ministre
d outre mer at il de nature à satisfaire
le président du département que
pense-t-il
aujourd'hui de ce gouvernement de cette
majorité qui l'a soutenu lors des
dernières élections européennes at il
l'intention d'entrer dans la mêlée les
municipales pour y faire quoi
où en est-il de ses relations avec le
président de la région et avec les
différents ténors de la droite
réunionnaise
quelle politique agricole pour le
département quelle politique
d'aménagement pour le territoire
cyrille melchior président du conseil
départemental est l'invitée d'un des
politiques sur la première jusqu'à 13h
vous question à partir de 12h45 au 0262
90 f 2000 culture bonjour bonjour
bonjour à vous et merci d'être
aujourd'hui en actualité d'abord il ya
ce ce procès du médiator qui démarre en
force alors on en a qui vont faire un
certain nombre de patients réunionnais
et qui pose aussi finalement la question
de l'industrie pharmaceutique de notre
relation à ses as aimé la façon dont
fonctionne cette industrie si vous
surfez s'est passé quelque chose qui
vous qui vous touche fait de l'actualité
votre touche c'est le dantec bien sûr ce
procès fait partie l'actualité et tout
citoyen concerné je pense notamment aux
personnes qui se sentent victimes de
l'utilisation de ce médicament qui ont
décidé de porter plainte
donc mon souhait c'est que s'il y a eu
bien problème que ce problème soit
réparé et que l'action de justice aille
justement vers la réparation donc de ses
victimes
je voudrais tout simplement dire que
département nous sommes bien sûr
attentif à ce que les familles
réunionnaises qui ont été victimes de
l'utilisation de ces médicaments
puisse-t-elle entendu exprimer leur
mécontentement et bénéficier des
réparations si réparation et la justice
le dira ces six mois dans l'actualité
également il ya ces difficultés pour les
compagnies aériennes qui concerne le
service est ce que c'est ce que vous
êtes inquiet pour les conséquences que
cela peut avoir pour le tourisme de
nombreux prix l'ailier pour se soucier
qui voudraient d'avoir une pensée pour
les clients réunionnais qui ont décidé
depuis un certain temps justement de
commencer à plier le billet d'avion et
qui s'habille et pensée pour ces
personnes une pensée aussi pour les
personnels qui travaillent au sein dixon
airways en ce cas chaque fois qu'une
entreprise risque de disparaître et bien
là aussi c'est du chômage qui qui
arrivent et donc nous sommes attentifs
moi je dirai tout simplement que ce
dossier et ce n'est pas la première fois
que des compagnies qui décide des
scélérats réunion un coût relativement
bas et bien moment donné ce disque on
n'en peut plus on va déposer le bilan
et à chaque fois ce sont les familles
réunionnaises qui en sont victimes
un moment donné je dis stop c'est vrai
qu'il faut de la concurrence
mais la concurrence ne doit pas à
profiter du marché réunionnais qui est
un manche et parfois de dos belle pour
ces entreprises qui viennent en se
disant on vers un beau manches et on va
casser la clientèle et puis au bout d'un
certain temps sous la porte
ce sont les familles réunionnaises qui
pâtissent encore une fois de ces
éléments et je ne peux que regretter sa
et dénoncer ces méthodes qui consistent
à venir ici pour les voir je vous
propose à bas coût des des produits et
au bout d'un set et rend les entreprises
reprend seul problème c'est que ces
entreprises repas disparaissent mais
qu'il ya des familles qui ont investi
dans le billet d'avion
c'est le kram istres des outre-mer
jardin
aussi la semaine dernière c'est un
nombre d'annoncés en détail mais
globalement vous dit merci madame la
ministre on dit c'est gentil mais au
niveau du compte on espère que les
maquereaux râler valises un peu plus
plein jeu c'est d'abord là aussi pareil
d'abord mais aussi aux réunionnaises et
réunionnais qui ont fait passer un
message à un moment donné on retient ce
gouvernement que le territoire de la
réunion des territoires en souffrance
dans lequel l'état le dois continuer à
s'investir et le département était
relais entre la population réunionnaise
et le gouvernement y voit même j'ai donc
exprimé certain nombre de demandes et
j'ai bien compris finalement pu marquer
sur la question posée sur la réponse
qu'elle claquait la porte et finalement
vous êtes satisfait ce que ce suffixe
que simplement la réponse du
gouvernement
je pense que là aussi elles 50 la façon
dont les demandes par des territoires et
pour voir ça c'est une nouveauté parce
que le gouvernant attendre le territoire
fasse preuve d'innovation d'imagination
parce que les plessis publics qui
doivent être menées ici j'ai exprimé
cette demande le gouvernement nous a
apporté des réponses ne dis pas que les
réponses suffisantes mais elles vont
quand même dans le sens où elles
permettent d'améliorer certain nombre de
choses à lario je pense par exemple
dossier des violences intrafamiliales je
pense au dessus du radier je pense de
ces de l'association des publics en
difficulté de la lutte contre la
pauvreté la précarité au dossier des
agriculteurs sont des dossiers où
j'estime que le gouvernement est en lien
avec nous et apporte des réponses qui en
tout cas vont dans le bon sens parce que
nous allons pouvoir mettre en place des
mesures concrètes
enfin des familles rennaise g d'oignon
fin octobre où vous en attendez quoi
j'attends que d'abord que le chef de
l'état s'exprime vers les réunionnaises
et les réunionnais parce que le chef de
l'état s'est quand même
l'exécutif national ccc le père de la
nation mais concrètement vous espérez
qu'ils arrivent avec des annonces
précises
quelque chose dans ce cas
bien sûr le chef de l'état doit apporter
des éléments de réponses sur des sujets
qui vous des exprimés par la population
réunionnaise comme si la grille la crise
sociale je pense par exemple en matière
de baisse des prix
eh bien on voit bien que l'observatoire
donc a été mise en place
produit donc un travail qui a des
questions qui sont posées
peut-être que ça va apporter des
éléments de réponse là dessus concernant
le pouvoir d'achat concernant aussi dans
des difficultés des familles
réunionnaises qui pourrait annoncer sur
le bois je ne sais pas j'attends quand
même qu'il puisse dire que ici à la
réunion en face justement la crise qu'il
ya sur le cv des mia eh bien quelle est
la vision de l'état sur ces dossiers le
prix d'achat c'est d'abord plus de
revenus ceux-ci baisser les prix avancés
de revenus j'attends que le chef de
l'état a demandé une réponse pour que
ceux qui ont les faits les revenus les
plus faibles
puis cela aussi est accompagné par
l'état nous avons amené sur la table un
dossier qui consiste à dire que ceux qui
bénéficient du rsa
et bien pendant le temps où ces
personnes vont se former bénéficient de
contrats saisonniers notamment dans le
domaine agricole que ces personnes
puissent bénéficier du cumul rsa revidât
t-il des revenus donc subsidiaire donc
c'est là des réponses que j'attends du
chef de l'état on travaille bien sûr sur
la baisse des prix mais aussi sur un
meilleur revenu pour ceux qui vivent aux
minima sociaux
globalement sur ce sur ce gouvernement
vous êtes tout satisfait où sont
élaborés en phase avec sa politique
générale sa politique économie sociale
totalement en face vous savez qu'il ya
encore des choses à améliorer mais je
dirais que par rapport à ce que j'ai pu
connaître dans le passé je trouve que
aujourd'hui il y à une forte activité du
gouvernement j'étais là-bas il y a lundi
mardi à huit jours pour parler à la
mission première des problèmes de pet
qui lie à la réunion dont la cessation
d'auguste de l'utilisation des pecs en
cette fin d'année qui pose problème
trente jours est arrivé réponse après je
dis pas que les réponses ont totalement
satisfait mais il y a de la réactivité
c'est ça qui est important les trop
contre avaient été consommées dans le
début de ces ce qu'a dit la préfecture
plus le bec pour finir 2019
vous êtes concerné des retours par 7,7
ce blocage qui qui se gèlent qui est
sûrement ce que nous savons des peuples
en tête dans les collèges par exemple
des personnes sous contrat aidé qui
travaillent dans les collèges qui
travaille sur les espaces naturels les
espaces forestiers et donc l'arrêt
brutal de l'utilisation des contrats de
ces contrats aidés aurait posé problème
c'est pour ça qu'il fallait rapidement
résultats longtemps vous connaissiez
lovelock globale pour l'année
je suis désolé vous interrompez à mon
sens pas vraiment de problème parce
qu'on était dans l'utilisation normale
de ce qui avait été prévu
mais sauf à un moment de sûr que ça
suffisait pas non sauf un moment donné
je n'ai pas trop compris pourquoi bien
dit cela dit si on ferme le robinet
alors qu ils étaient 1500 contrats non
utilisés mais les collectivités
je parle prend le département nous
n'étions pas ses parents sur la
consommation on est en train d'utiliser
ce qui avait été prévu
donc il y a eu pour moi c'était juste
pour permettre aux ministres de l'ocs en
fait mais toujours est il que nous
sommes quand même contents passer d'une
situation de blocage
finalement il y aura mille de plus tant
qu est-ce que c'est suffisant 1000 de
plus ce que le est ce que c'est ce qui
est ce que finalement c est qu est-ce
qui remplissent leur rôle d'insertion
souffle je vais dire les emplois aidés
existants on n'en veut plus on veut
vraiment d'insertion de contrat mais
est-ce que c'est ce que c'est plus
efficace que 1000 de plus ça change
quelque chose
oui de plus vous savez c'est bien sûr
que c'est très positif
le territoire c'est très positif parce
que je vous ai dit qu'il ya des besoins
et ses besoins font que quand il aura
les 1000 de plus et bien sûr ça les
maires les associations les
collectivités territoriales comme les
bravos région nous allons pouvoir plus
de moyens à disposition notamment des
collèges mais je vous dirais que c'est
vrai que l'association n'a pas été
suffisamment parle pas assez prises en
compte et je regrette mais je dis que
aujourd'hui il ya une vraie volonté
d'aller vers plus
sion c'est pour cela que j'ai présenté
un plan ambitieux avec l'ensemble des
élus du département à l'unanimité nous
avons voté un rapport aux titres de
l'expérimentation
nous voulons proposer à l'état et
proposé aux familles qui sont
bénéficiaires du rsa de pouvoir à 5000
d'entre elles allaient bien disposition
au titre là aussi des emplois qui se
créent ici ceux que je porte le projet
de création d'un cfa des métiers d'aidé
à la personne en ce qu'il ya le vise
c'est un sens de formation des apprentis
il y a avec le vieillissement de la
population sait bien que les plus de 60
ans vont le nombre et sommes au doublé
dans les 15 ans qui viennent
il nous faut donc bien par de nouveaux
métiers de vrais métiers de vrais
métiers des vrais emplois avec de vrais
emplois pendant ce temps là les pecs
c'est pas ça il faut tendre vers ça et
donc nous tendons vers justement ouvrir
de nouvelles niches d'emplois pour
celles et ceux qui voudront qui
passeront par le sas de la formation de
deuxième mais je vous parle de ça mais
je vous parle aussi des métiers liés à
l'environnement nous nous parlons tous
de transition écologique
environnementale je suis persuadé qu'au
titre de l'économie circulaire il a des
possibilités d'associations durable voix
celles et ceux qui aujourd'hui sont au
chômage
mes courses et comment est-ce qu'on crée
ces emplois aujourd'hui ce qu'on
construit à ce que vous dites pas ce que
c'est d autant plus qu il faudrait donc
pas forcément des emprunts publics je
pense que l'économie marchande est prête
à prendre le relais mais pour ça il nous
faut mettre en formation il nous faut
préparer donc les personnes à aller ces
emplois je rencontre ici les chefs
d'entreprise qui me disent monsieur le
président je veux recruter à la personne
je veux recruter parce qu'il vit à la
demande
il y adeux l'offre d'emploi mais il faut
qu'on va être en adéquation l'offre de
formation et les offres d'emploi et ses
poissons pour ce plan ambitieux pour des
bars département 20 pm est bien le lien
entre ces offres d'emploi et les publics
et qui a tendu essentielle sera de
projets c'est l'un des projets les plus
avancés par ce que les
ans vont sentir cet amour d'ici la fin
de l'année et je veux peux vous annoncer
que par exemple dans les métiers
d'agriculture où là aussi en réclame de
la main d'oeuvre
eh bien on va aller vers certainement la
possibilité pour le pénis et du rsa de
garder le bénéfice de ces minima sociaux
mais de pouvoir avoir un complément de
revenu l'autre source de l'amisom vous
concerne directement
8 millions d'euros pour le budget du
plan d'élimination gratin compris d'où
venait cet argent et des questions 2
finalement de de rapatrier de
redistribuer l'argent qui n'est pas
utilisé pour le logement on se dit c'est
pas possible avec le nogentais reste à
construire
comment est ce que l'argent qui était
prévu pour ça on peut ne pas être
dépensés quoique là mais je ne peux pas
répondre à la place de la mise mais
j'imagine que l'état effectivement
devant la la sous consommation des
crédits a sollicité et collectivités le
département a répondu présent presse que
vous avez des projets prêts à démarrer
parce que appelé dans une île qui
souffre d'un chômage de près de 24%
alors même qu'il ait un manque
d'activité d'emploi et enfin s'il ya des
besoins d'aménagement eh bien allons
mettre en chantier le maximum de choses
avant la fin d'année seront pas
consommer les crédits disponibles et
donc j'ai présenté le dossier du
département ce plan radier le suis
content heureux que l'état le programme
en est répondu favorablement
ça veut dire là aussi que les familles
qui circulent parfois dans les eaux
essaiera microrégion des eaux qu'il est
directement concerné ces familles un
petit à petit on va la refaire les
conditions de sécurité beaucoup plus
meilleur aujourd'hui
je pense aussi que dans certaines zones
comme entre saint pierre c'est lui le
radier du ouaki qui h apéro cyclonique
disparaît qu'ils passent plus la ramener
les études techniques
ça veut dire que nous allons
concrètement m au budget donc
l'année prochaine les crédits pour que
d'ici un an qu'on puisse dire justement
aux salisiens simple roi voilà ce qu'on
va faire je ne peux pas promettre on
peut juger parce que les études n'ont
pas démarré mais retraite de l'état va
pouvoir avancer vers le règlement du
radigois qui a plusieurs ratés dans
partout dans l'île mais dans le sud et
l'ouest on continue dans les hauts de
saint-paul où nous attendons des
améliorations et les 7 millions de
l'état qui sont annoncés pour cette fin
d'année rentrer à ce dispositif et vont
nous permet d'aller beaucoup plus
rapidement plus loin au bénéfice des
usagers de la route
les dirigeants la naissance à new york
points 5 ans aujourd'hui par un sommet
sur l'urgence climatique
on a vu encore des manifestations ce
week-end pour le climat en as le
sentiment que l'urgence voilà c'est tout
le monde l'accepté ya effectivement une
urgence climatique qui s'impose à nous
et pourtant que les décideurs politiques
ne faut pas grand chose pour répondre à
cette urgence qu'on est toujours dans
des plans qui vaut dans les années qui
viennent peut-être commencer à la
question que faites-vous décideurs
politiques là en urgence pour répondre à
cette question
enfin sujet comme celui là le
département nous avions travaille depuis
longtemps sur l'urgence sociale et nous
avons décidé de qui peut être lié leur
imaginaire les deux sont lise passage
les airs de l'urgence sociale et
l'urgence climatique deux ans climatique
c'est un sujet complexe mais on va s'y
atteler
j'ai tout et on doit s'y atteler
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est ce que vous
répondez à ces églises ne vous ne faites
rien si dès le départ a déjà énormément
contre préserve la forêt réunionnaise
quand on lutte contre les risques d
incendie ben c'est une façon si d'agir
pour protéger notre planète pour
protéger notre line up pour protéger la
biodiversité
quand sur l'étang saint paul nous
travaillons en lien mairies associations
population pour protéger cette vaste
étang de saint paul et bien c'est une
action concrète que l'on met dans la
préservation de la biodiversité
d'ailleurs ce travail a été reconnu en
plus haut lieu donc il y à des actions
qu'ils sont
né notamment la gelée si dans tout ce
qui est protection d'environnement
quand on travaille les associations pour
protéger la faune de l'eau vive hier
c'est aussi une façon d'agir pour
protéger notre planète et nous avons
créé une s quel s p edel doit justement
donner plus de consistance encore à
l'implication du département dans tout
ce qui touche la préservation de
l'environnement
concrètement ce sont les espaces
naturels sensibles les espaces forissier
les étangs sur lesquels le des bras
on travaille depuis plusieurs années et
nous venons chaque joueur a une
politique tournée vers justement la
protection de l'environnement et de la
planète et en même temps de dire que
c'est peut-être plus la sensibilité des
régions que le département ton toujours
dans la voiture
les projets de déplacements de transport
ou en sortent un peu mais ils sont sur
les rails j'ose dire mais qu'encore 20
bornes à ses déplacements c'est vrai que
en tout cas nous nous privilégions aussi
donc de plus en plus le mode électrique
le département est en train d'investir
je dois vous le dire on apprend qu
automobile pour aller vers l'électrique
nous sommes en train de travailler aussi
voir sur les routes départementales
au fait le maximum de pistes cyclables à
ceux qui veulent utiliser ce que pour
cent sur les terrains des pistes
cyclables a pas beaucoup je ne conçois
pas ce que nos routes soient anciennes
mais nous faut sera je le sens
résolument engagé aller le plus loin
possible avec eux y a du retard ça je le
conçois mais on avance que vous avez
saisi la ministre qui sont liées à
l'agriculture lors de la rencontre qu'il
a eue avec
avant cela difficulté d'exporter des
fruits à cause de contrôle douanier
supplémentaires trop long compliqué le
temps pour escorter les fruits par avion
elle a répondu lors de sa visite répondu
mouche orientale quelle est la situation
aujourd'hui pour les agriculteurs est ce
qu'il faut d'ailleurs se permettaient je
voudrais aussi parce que dans le domaine
a décollé avec beaucoup d'action qui
sont faites pour protéger là aussi nos
terres je pense par exemple au nom des
agriculteurs qui s'étendent des cultures
avoir aimé mes chaussures sur ce site
est précise de l'export sur l'escaut
nous avons un cap et la milice a pas
seulement vrai mais aussi les
professionnels sur les risques ne pas
pour faire passer de fouilles en cette
fin d'année doit se tenir cette semaine
on va voir une table ronde autour du
préfet des acteurs nous mêmes pour
justement rechercher les solutions mais
c'est vrai qu'il ya un vrai risque
il faut le dire par rapport aux 7 est la
bouche orientale qui est arrivé qui ont
envahi nos sens nous avons travaillé
avec la fédération des donc la lutte
contre les espèces envahissantes pour
justement aller le plus loin possible
les les agriculteurs qui sont donc qui
pratiquent la culture des fruits
bénéficient de l'accompagnement de la
région pour installer des pièges mais
c'est vrai que malgré tout les élus qui
sont menées les recherches et mener
aussi est bien là la bouche elle est là
ils servent risque alors je ne peux pas
vous dire quels seront les résultats de
ses travaux et je sais que le service de
la daf travail auprès des agriculteurs
pressé de trouver la meilleure des
solutions
les pros l'instant il n'y a pas encore
de solution il faut l'avouer on se
complaît la culture et c'est un trou
dans son histoire avec la fin des des
quotas sucriers une très forte de la
population d'une alimentation plus saine
des brassées produits chimiques pareils
à ceux qui se mettent au bio il ya ceux
qui quittent ils peuvent pas qu'ils
veulent pas ça a confié qu'elle est la
ligne que vous si les meilleurs vous
défendez
vous avez toujours entend bien défendre
tout le monde en même temps mais là il
va falloir à un moment choisi une
politique va ouvrir quelle agriculture
et quelle vie notation avec une soirée
lyonnaise durant ces trente dernières
années à faire bas un pas considérable a
gagné en qualité
elle a gagné en quantité et ateliers en
crédibilité auprès des consommateurs
réunionnais aujourd'hui nous sommes
maintenant en ce que beaucoup de
questions se posent quant à l'avenir de
la can
et si on se pose quand un tel des
cultures comme l'a dit avec une avec une
phrase ou raisonnée ou bio les parents
accompagnent cette mutation et je suis
content de prendre se présentait nous
dise quand je les croise pour nous dire
qu'on a besoin de cet accompagnement des
pouvoirs publics et notamment du
département parce que le département
c'est l'institution de proximité et les
incultes et aujourd'hui le mode de
fonctionnement avec une réunionnaise est
parti d'une agriculture familiale
n'avons pas des normes d'exploitation
sont des agricultures à l'échelle
familiale et les familles sont en lien
avec le département
c'est pour ça que nous allons
privilégier dans les années qui viennent
nous avons travaillé sur le plan agréé
2020 2030 qui fixe les orientations ce
travail a été mené en partenariat avec
les producteurs eux mêmes
le but recherché c'est quoi c'est
d'abord une meilleure banque au plus
loin dans la qualité environnementale
c'est à dire l'agriculture raisonnée
deuxièmement ce que vous êtes pour
l'introduction de l'ifo d'un seul parent
sur les forêts réunionnaises
je peux vous le dire que le nfl demande
du département n'utilise pas d'utiliser
plus ce produit
oui et d'eau chaude dans les champs car
ils sont quatre à vivre
la lutte en ont fait défaut et non en
basse et de maîtrise des techniques de
production
donc je ne vais pas leur imposer
d'utiliser tel je sais que certains peu
de produits sont passés dans des prisons
mais savait que ils ont fait quand même
beaucoup d'efforts et je sais que par
exemple aussi de l'agriculture bio et
bien le la surface qui est utilisé
aujourd'hui va être doublé là encore
d'aller dans les deux trois années qui
viennent accompagnés par les produits
chimiques y compris ceux qui sont
potentiellement que ce qui est sûr c'est
que l'agriculture réunionnaise a gagné
en qualité et je peux vous assurer que
quand je vois ce qui se fait et bien il
y à la demande à l'expo il ya aussi de
la demande ici localement les produits
réunionnais nous en sommes fiers
nous sommes fiers de la tonne avec les
réunionnaises c'est un travail acharné
et ce travail est récompensé parce qu'on
voit des halles à narva des fruits on va
des légumes de qualité ici bien sûr sur
les marchés régulés mais aussi il faut
bien le dire
notre souhait c'est que le marché des
cantines scolaires de la tête de plus en
plus approvisionné par la douceur
possible justement de répondre aux
exigences de la loi
kelly ou seule alimentation et u qui
impose à partir du 20 novembre un repas
dans les cantines qui impose à partir de
2020 de 20% de bio 50% des cultures
raisonnées
le tout dans une hausse in devant de
deux circuits courts de production
locale est-ce que ce que la réunion
pourra faire ça pour l'instant on y voit
en importe beaucoup en importe beaucoup
mais je peux aussi par et le taux
d'utilisation des pots durée donnée à la
fabrication des repas aux modes sans
cesse et je suis content et nous devons
avoir le plus loin possible
nous allons pouvoir répondre à cette loi
par exemple ce qui concerne fabrication
des repas végétariens
nous allons aller le plus loin possible
l'utilisation des produits
j'avais culture raisonnée bioval
voici cinq ans pas sûr qu'on puisse
antenne je suis franc avec vous la date
limite en ce que larry notre territoire
où nous avons cumulé tellement de temps
que ce retour ne peuvent pas être
rattrapés comme en france métropolitaine
en l'espace de trois quatre ans on vient
qui est précieux aussi du lobbying de la
part des agriculteurs qui se bat non
nous on veut parce que parce que c'est
parce que c'est difficile par son père
devenu et que les pouvoirs publics
disent oui il faut vers le bio on va
vous accompagner mais ça prend beaucoup
trop de temps qu'on ne sait pas assez
vite on n'avance pas assez vite je le
comprends bien la vence quand même et si
on faisait du chantage aurait dit oui là
tout est critiquable à on avance quand
même mais vous savez ce territoire comme
la réunion confrontés à des situations
géographiques compliqué avec les risques
cycloniques trois cyclones année
dernière sur le monde agricole
trois cyclones vous voyez pas ça en
métropole
donc un marché étroit l'éloignement est
branché nous sommes en situation
tropicale avec les risques de maladies
qui étaient à cannes comme la mouche des
fruits horizontale donc tout cela
complique le travail de nos agriculteurs
c'est pour ça que moi représente les
parents et l'ensemble des conseillers
départementaux
nous sommes résolument encore une fois
offensif motivé pour accompagner le
monde des arts et culture et je sais que
il a la qualité qui est produit il y à
la quantité
quand je vois ce qui se fait dans les
champs aujourd'hui ambassades aux fruits
et légumes libre à vos agriculteurs mais
bien sûr qu'il reste des efforts à faire
il convient de les accompagner les
parties de sa visite à la lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes vous
avez annoncé du coup de pouce du
département en écho
sa consistance et quatre assistances
sociales qui seront dans les lieux
ferrand d'accueil de ces enfants qui
sont qui est une porte plainte
alors c'est vrai que l département sur
cette obligation de l'état d'accompagner
les familles victimes de violences et
vers le département n'est pas sensible
nous accompagnons les efforts de l'état
et dans les polices et gendarmeries
il a été acté le fait qu'il puisse avoir
des assistant familial payé par
littéralement par l'état et le
département et ce nombre était de 4 nous
allons le doublé tout simplement parce
que les assistantes familiales francs un
rôle important d'écouter le dialogue
avec notamment les femmes victimes de
ces violences et je pense aussi aux
conséquences que ces violences peuvent
avoir sur les enfants de ces familles
c'est pour cela qu'il nous apprend siens
là aussi de renforcer les moyens et plus
d'assistante familiale devra plus c'est
deux fois plus des gouttes parce que le
nombre de dossiers de 1200 assistant
familial on pouvait très bien ce que je
dis ça ça reste faible voilà les moyens
sont pas à la hauteur de l'enjeu
le verbe raté vide le dis toujours que
ce qu'on peut faire et tout ça c'est
insuffisant je le conçois mais on part
de loin
il ya tellement de temps un peu partout
le nombre de structures d'accueil
j'entendis ce qu'a annoncé madame la
ministre n'a pas d'état j'ai dit que si
la demande est là projet pour moi que le
nombre de places jugé aujourd'hui
insuffisant le département accompagnera
les efforts qui seront faits pour
augmenter le nombre de places
sabourin ça paraît normal dans
l'activité de réseaux du département il
viaggio le doublement des assistant
familial réponse hier sa demande
c'est qu'est ce que vous avez envie de
participer aux prochaines élections
municipales mars je serai présent d'une
façon ou d'une autre je ne fais pas être
mais je dois vous le dire tout
simplement parce que je suis très pris
par le président du département
je suis très sollicité j'ai beaucoup de
dossiers qui avance et d'autres qui
n'avance pas suffisamment donc je dois
m'investir pleinement dans mon rôle de
président je serais bien sûr présent
parce que vous avez bien remarqué depuis
mon arrivée à la présence des projets
renouer elle est très fort et que
l'ensemble des 24 municipalités
tout simplement parce que les propos et
les mairies des communes travaillent
fort l'action sociale donc ce serait
présent à saint paul je serai là c'est
parce que vous parce que vous y êtes élu
vous aviez publié quelques semaines une
tribune il tapa ambiguës aux demandes et
justement si vous voulez il ya donc là
vous exercez vous n'y allez pas vous
même mais quoi cette tribune c'est
qu'ici vous avez vous voulez vous voulez
qu'ils n'ont pas la population a choisi
son maire quel que soit le choix de la
population en grand démocrate que je
suis je l'accepterais le verdict des
yeux mais ce qu'on sait c'est que
symbole comment sa famille politique je
vais principe de la famille des droites
je dirais donc ses bras est clair
aujourd'hui la travail qui a été fait
depuis 2004 aux par le maire joseph
sinimalé
donc j'estime que ce travail n'est pas
terminé là aussi quand je vois les
autres aussi la légitimité pour conduire
la prochaine liste
maintenant ça ne se fait pas sans
dialogue avec les autres qui sont aussi
qu'ils veulent présenter une liste est
donc le dialogue a commencé il continue
et j'espère qu'il y aura au symbole une
belle liste pour en encore une fois
poursuivre et franck été commencées qui
finalement quand on y regarde de près le
bilan de l'équipe 130 et du maire centre
n'est pas si mauvais que cela avec le
doublement des crédits consacrés aux
écoles et dans beaucoup de domaines
savoir avancer contrairement à ce que
certaines personnes ici
ces micros posés sur les politiques je
veux une question au standard puisque
c'est emilie qui nous a appelés et
militaires en question
bonjour voilà donc départementale quels
sont vos moyens
à quels moyens avez mieux vous êtes élu
pour améliorer le traitement des
dossiers mdph
parce que à l'heure actuelle on nous dit
six mois d'attentes sur sur le site
internet mais bon on est bien au-delà
des défis moi quoi donc je voulais
savoir vous quels moyens vous à venir le
président merci merci beaucoup militent
pour votre question ces questions
important c'est une des responsabilités
du débutant mais les caps et les aides
qui sont mises en oeuvre pour
accompagner
vivement plus tard alors c'est vrai que
en ce moment un débat je sais qu'il ya
des modifications de logiciels qui
entraîne cette oeuvre autant mais je
dois vous dire que la consigne a été
donnée par moi-même à mdph ses dédales à
travers la présentation de td de ses
tableaux
c'est de montrer qu'elle est
l'amélioration de ses délais de
traitement des dossiers
six mois c'est trop long combat en
perspective
c'est plus effectivement plus d'écouté
plus de rapidité dans le traitement pas
forcément plus d'effectifs parce que la
solution c'est vite passé
non c'est que en ce moment il y à la
mise en place d'un nouveau traitement
par logiciel des dossiers qui perturbe
un peu le fonctionnement de ses services
moi je fais confiance de directement des
berges monsieur dvâravatî ce qui fait
qu'à ses services
mais je consomme près les dossiers
n'avancent pas suffisamment vite c'est
pour cela que j'y veille et lors de la
dernière réunion d'ailleurs lorsque lisa
soit un état était passé bien insister
là dessus c'est que il y a enfin les
berges des familles qui sont en
souffrance qu'elles attendent une
réponse et ses réponses trop je le
conçois c'est pour ça que
ben vous répondre de quels moyens sans
passeport tout simplement de la
réactivité de la part des services même
des biens cela passe par une meilleure
organisation
mais je sais que le directeur soit dès
qu'on fait de la politique la culture
vous avez vous fait partie des
personnalités qui ont été qui était dans
ce baromètre par s'agisse pour agir et
non la première baromètre qu'il vous
donne 56% d'opinions favorables et 25 %
de mauvaises opinions
finalement ça montre quoi une certaine
bonne et plus doublions savoir que
défavorable mais 25%
c'est comme si finalement beaucoup de
gens étaient assez indifférent
finalement à votre personnalité et votre
politique ce que vous n'êtes pas encore
bien rentré dans la vie politique où
régnerait dans les personnalités
religieuses
moi je veux rester comme je suis c'est à
dire quelqu'un qui ne veut pas faire de
la politique politicienne elle que qui
s'est engagé à faire avancer les
dossiers de son département
je ne suis pas formaté comme certains
pouvoirs avec les polémiques
je suis quelqu'un qui travaille sont
recherchées france aimant le
sensationnel et c'est vrai que peut-être
brossette elle rayonnait bain
le travail que je fais n'est pas
suffisamment bien perçu mais je veux
dire ce qui était important pour moi
c'est d'avancer de faire avancer les
dossiers de son département et après le
vatican dans les yeux les électeurs
s'expriment
si à un moment donné eh bien vous voyez
que ces mesures n'étaient pas
suffisamment groupe étant d'office
faisait pas assez
et bien elle que pour s'exprimer mais je
suis encore une fois
résolument très vert on travaille au
quotidien pour faire en série de
scénarios ou est-ce que vous en êtes
avec vos partenaires vous dire une
droite au droit auquel on sait à quel
point le conflit entre dire aux gars
même si faute à 10,7 droite réunionnaise
où est-ce qu'on en est où est ce que
vous allez vous avec les autres c'est
vrai parfois là aussi nous faisons
partie d'un territoire où les uns les
autres et ce prime des convergences
parfois des divergences mais je dis que
ce qui est important ce n'est pas de
savoir ce que pense à untel ou untel est
de savoir ce que l'on fait pas à riom
pour les familles réunionnaises et donc
c'est comme ça que j'appelle toujours
les uns les autres à rester dans les
alpages et rencontrer didier robert oui
j'ai rencontré le président du conseil
régional pour me dire que le départ
qu'on a raison je représente doit
travailler on est relativisée régionales
je pense que moi le message est passé
mon souhait c'est que il y ait dialogue
entre les uns et les autres mais il me
semble que ça vient comme tu sais ce que
ça veut dire que la droite peut se
réconcilier à refaire sa plateforme qui
vous avait permis de remporter la région
le département
est ce que vous les municipales vous
allez diviser ensemble soit la question
c'est de savoir quel projet pour la
réunion à savoir ce que sk talent face
aux lettres intéresse que la plateforme
à se faire c'est bien c'est difficile
compliqué c'est sûr il faut qu'on
s'entende pour construire ensemble et
faire avancer la réunion et avancer la
réunion autour d'un projet on aura
construit ensemble et ça ce n'est pas
impossible mais ça c'est de la langue ne
vois pas ce que les verts ont tourné
d'accord pour faire avancer la régler la
question la question c'est est ce que la
droite peut se réconcilier avant mars
alors j'y crois je suis d'analysé j'y
crois et je travaille pour que tout le
monde se parle
nous avons un appel pour vous téléphone
c'est janning qui nous avaient de 20,5 à
une question pour vous écouter une
bonjour bonjour voila je suis dans une
situation très très très très très mal
j'ai ma maman qu'est à qui j'ai pris la
responsabilité de la poignée et eux elle
a que 20 à 30 eur de dettes de dap et à
la synchronisation elle et on
diagnostique on n'a pas encore décidé
mais c'est un point qu'elle est là la
maladie d'alzheimer mais elle en a fait
des familles d'accueil à la faille des
foyers elle ne résiste pas pour elles
sont bien laisser des dettes chez elle
alors je voudrais savoir à qui
m'adresser
pourquoi je puisse expliquer mon cas et
trouver une situation à cela merci merci
jeanine pour votre belle madame votre
cas cet appel c'est pour ça que la
première des solutions c'est le passé
par l'arrondissement sud où il ya les
travailleurs sociaux
vous avez donc le service de l'aide
sociale aux adultes nasa qui sont
normalement qui sont là pour vous
écouter et travailler avec vous à votre
écoute
maintenant si vous le permettez syrie
dont la première est d'accord pour que
je puisse recueillir les données donc
votre numéro de téléphone
je demanderai je vous appellerai pour
avoir directement
il vous apporter une réponse adaptée par
une réponse à votre dossier mais vous
répondre votre orientation sur la
personne que vous
confronté je vous appellerai globalement
vous le disiez il faut développer aussi
les deux personnes aux personnes âgées
l'aide à la personne c'est un secteur
qui tente à nouveau président la
question des gens veulent rester chez
eux même s'ils sont dépendants et est-ce
qu'on peut y arriver est ce que le
département moyens
oui d'ailleurs pas plus tard que ce
mercredi nous allons présenter un
dossier sénatrice nassimah dindar est
habilité pour trouver un mode à prix
intermédiaire les maisons des
accueillants familiaux et donc un
premier de ces rapaces et sur saint
denis et cela veut dire qu'on sera veut
dire que nous privilégions le mot
d'accueil familial pour les personnes
âgées les personnes qui se retrouvent
dans des situations difficiles
isolé dans ce mot d'accueil familial
soit au sein même de la famille avec des
aidants familiaux soit en intermedia
avec la maison des appuis en familiaux
c'est ce que nous préconisons je dirais
que notre souhait c'est d'éviter que les
personnes âgées se sentent isolés
abandonnés par la société nous avons un
devoir de solidarité ces personnes c'est
pour cela que avec le département nous
avons travaillé à mettre en place un
plan pour les seniors je vous ai dit
aussi bien la population des personnes
âgées a doublé à la réunion il faut
appréhender le g le problème de l'eau g
sous plusieurs angles
l'accueil à domicile le meilleur accueil
les problématiques de l'animation dans
la vie commence que le drame se
retrouvent d'accompagnement si des
étangs parce que les personnes âgées
sont accompagnés par des fins dix
membres en fête de famille qui elle-même
rencontre d'autres problèmes surtout ses
juges et le département travaille
nous allons donc y apporter des réponses
dans le cadre du plan donc possédions
avait comme je voulais 10 pour former un
peu pauvre du pays ne le font que les
entreprises veulent recruter
on va mettre 1000 personnes sur les
trois prochaines années en formation est
à la personne l'amitié d'état essonne
302 cette année une question en fin
d'émission
avant votre avis demain à l'assemblée
nationale va commencer le débat sur la
pma procréation médicalement assistée
qui qui va évidemment intéressé tout le
monde toute la population va j'imagine
fusent aussi de près qu'elle est vous y
mettiez votre position vous savez nous
vivons dans une société qui évolue sans
cesse sur le dossier la pma je vois
qu'il faut faire attention à ne pas
franchir malgré tout le sel de ce qui
est peut-être ses tables en matière
d'éthique
donc moi je suis attentif à suivre ce
dossier je n'ai pas de réponse toute
prête
parce que à 30 au de voir comment les à
la discussion de la loi va s'engager
mais je suis attentif à ce que il ya un
problème d'éthique ce problème ne soit
pas je dis que je ne sois pas franchi
est-ce que ça va être un dossier qui va
votre avis aux intéressés les lieux il
va falloir que les personnalités
politiques se positionne en outre nous
avons des parlementaires chacun doit
aussi faire son travail de contents du
départ est attentif à tous ses
parlementaires
merci merci beaucoup c'est le même camp
d'avoir été avec nous pour ce lundi que
les tic y insère la première dans un mot
musique bien sûr avec sonia une
excellente après-midi sur réunion 1ère
12h15 à 13h le club de la presse sur la
première on va parler des élections
européennes il faut d'accord sur rien
sauf une chose qu'ils foutent micro
ondes
il y avait une vraie tentative de
conjonction entre 0 berre est jeune et
qu'on soit pour ou contre moi je vous
dis je suis ni pour ni contre le club de
la presse tous les mardis de 12h15 à 13h
avec gueye le dantec sur la première du
8 septembre au 6 octobre réunion la
première radio vous fera vivre la
tournée des aidants familiaux vous aider
un proche malade porteur de handicap ou
dépendants vous êtes un aidant familial
l'action sociale du groupe crc organise
sur toute l'île des activités qui vous
sont offertes prenait enfin du temps
pour vous plus d'informations sur groupe
crc point com
[Musique]
je vais tourner des aidants familiaux
une initiative de l'action sociale du
groupe crc chef d'entreprise
investissez dans l'océan indien et en
afrique rendez-vous au 12e forum
économique des îles de l'océan indien du
25 au 27 septembre à saint denis
au programme conférences ateliers
rencontres be to be fait cap vers
l'afrique et saisissez les opportunités
d'affaires sur www.fortis.com une
organisation de la cci de la réunion et
de lucé cio i avec le soutien de
l'europe la région réunion et l'afd la
région réunion présente shéhérazade de
rimski korsakov parle orchestres de la
région réunion sous la direction
artistique de thierry boyer trois
concerts à ne pas manquer le 27
septembre à champ fleuri
le 28 septembre au tampon et le 29
septembre à saint benoît le programme
symphonique pour 60 musiciens
comprendrait également des extraits
d'opéras de grandes oeuvres classiques
et cinématographique
plus d'infos sur le site conservatoire
point région reunion.com
merci à vous d'avoir choisi la première
il est 13 heures
[Musique]
voici les titres du journal de france
info servi at il caché pendant 30 ans la
dangerosité du médiator réponse dans six
mois au terme du procès qui s'ouvre
aujourd'hui au palais de justice de
paris
une première semaine consacrée aux
questions prioritaires de
constitutionnalité au coeur des débats
comment ce médicament largement détourné
comme coupe-faim ont-ils pu